ok servus skills und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video in dem ich heute
über das thema veränderung mit euch
reden möchte
ihr habt schon im titel gesehen das war
ich dass es so ein sinnbild für das
thema veränderung und das heute alles
drehen sollen dem video denn ich habe
mir jetzt zeit viel viele gedanken um
das thema veränderung gemacht das soll
jetzt gar nicht wie eine traurige
stimmung haben oder so das video aber
ich hab halt auch wieso man sagen als
oder nachdenkt ihr seid nicht aber kein
problem gefühle zu zeigen dass man muss
nicht immer alles um geschrei sein und
zehn minuten jump cuts und ich hoffe ihr
wisst das auch zu schätzen dass ich als
ultimo mit euch gespräche also diese er
zur seite ist einfach ein teil meiner
persönlichkeit den ich einfach auf
youtube juni nicht zensieren möchte ich
habe ich lust dazu mache ich halt
einfach los jetzt dass wir jetzt mal
deswegen kommt jetzt dieses video
übrigens geheimtipp fragt unbedingt mal
eure eltern nach euren alten fotos glaub
mir das ist richtig richtig gut kann ich
sowieso darüber zu lachen oder du so ein
bewusstsein dafür bekommt was man alles
schon schön war mir gab es in diesem
mega bit sowie sarah selbst gefühlen
diesem moment in dem ich auf diese fotos
geschossen so krass das was du und das
was du und das war's durch vergleich
einige zeigen jetzt bist du wieder eine
ganz andere person und darum soll es
gehen um das thema veränderungen und um
die fähigkeit von leuten sich selbst zu
verändern ich habe übrigens kein skript
oder so was für dieses video bock ab und
haben einfach hingesetzt und lara jetzt
freier von mit seele und ich hoffe dass
es im jahr kommt bei euch deswegen
fangen wir an mit einem foto das war ich
das ist ein foto da war ich glaube ich
kann die arbeit war ich darauf zehn
glaube ich und ja diese person war ich
auch vor gar nicht allzu langer zeit
also ich bin jetzt 20 vor zehn jahren
war ich diese person jetzt mal ehrlich
hätte nämlich erkannt auf dem bild wenn
man die tabelle sind ineinander gestellt
hätte stellt es auf meinem kopf vor ich
jetzt 20 und ich diesen bild 10 handy
uns erkannt
hättet ihr uns eingeschoben gesagt okay
das ist die gleiche person darum soll es
eben so gehen in diesem video vor allem
fachleute die es gerade eine schlechte
zeit durchmachen
zwischen diesen beiden bildern lagen
zehn jahre und rein äußerlich hat sich
extrem viel verändert und was sich
innerlich verändert hat es ist so was
ist eigentlich unbegreiflich also
persönlich und mental hat sich so so so
so so viel verändert bei mir seitdem ich
war damals ich glaube mega mega
frustriert hatte keine freunde war
relativ unsportlich war schlechte der
schule und jetzt gerade mal zehn jahre
später ist einfach alles komplett anders
für mich ich hab jetzt ich habe
ausreichend freunde so dass es mir
gefällt ich habe ausreichend freundliche
viele viele kumpels und bekannte ich
früher gar nicht ich bin nicht immer
nicht so der aller beliebteste meiner
uni oder so aber das kommt auf jeden
fall noch ich weiß dass es noch kommt
ich habe mich was meinen kopf angeht
auch extrem verbessert ich bin viel
zufriedener mit mir selbst jetzt und vor
allem auch aus die sportlichkeit angeht
das ist eine entwicklung die man in
letzter zeit sehr viel spaß macht und
mich mit viel energie gibt ehrlich
gesagt
deswegen kann ich das nur empfehlen so
zu sehen dass man wenn man zeit und
bisschen leidensbereitschaft investiert
in einen körper so sehr verändern kann
das ist das eine sehr motivierende
erfahrung also ich kann jedem empfehlen
oder schauen wir uns mal anderes bild an
das hier zum beispiel
da war ich glaube ich 1314 sondern einer
konfirmation
mal ganz davon abgesehen dass ich wie
wie kann man so eine krawatte und so ein
hemd trabis gesehen eine rosa gestreifte
krawatte und niveau seines hemd meine
fresse und ihr seht auch bisschen
irgendwie zwei komplett unterschiedliche
personen und wenn man die nebenan der
held warte ich halt mal so das sieht man
schon gewisse unterschied würde ich
sagen oder die sache ist dass es gar
nicht so lange her dass wir unter euch
1314 als heißt es in nur sechs jahren 61
jetzt für jemand der vielleicht 14 ist
oder so viel an aber okay das auch viel
zeit eigentlich aber auch so ein leben
gerechnet ist es halt ungefähr gar
nichts wenn man daran denkt wie sehr
sich mein leben seitdem verändert hat
das einfach die schweiz begreifen
deswegen mich auf dieses video machen
wir müssen nur zu reden ist es jetzt
sehr chaotisch aber ich hoffe irgendwer
von euch versteht so meine energie bei
diesem video und motivation man kann da
vielleicht etwas rausnehmen was ich euch
auf jeden fall sagen möchte ist ihr
könnt euer leben verändern und damit
meine ich nicht diese fitness bullshit
blabla kacke von wegen bietet best
joking bien so ein scheiß das ist auch
absoluter bullshit älter
letzten endes sind wir immer noch
menschen und keine maschinen die dafür
gemacht sind sich irgendwie selbst zu
optimieren in jeder hinsicht wird
irgendwie 0 freizeit zu haben immer
produktiv zu sein
im geringsten körperfettanteil zu haben
die beste note zu schreiben und fehler
sind menschlich ist fehler machen
menschen auch menschlich wenn dich
deswegen habe ich auf diese sich selbst
optimiere rey in jeder hinsicht
überhaupt keinen bock
aber zu sehen dass man dinge verändern
kann wenn man zeit investiert ist
einfach eine unfassbar geile erfahrung
und die habe ich echt lange nicht
gemacht also ich glaube die erfahrung
kam erst so glaube ich mit 20 so im
letzten jahr erst bis dahin habe ich
mich immer so treiben lassen
viele entscheidungen in meinem leben
getroffen habe wohl und vor anderen
mitbestimmt und wahrscheinlich hätte ich
nie so wirklich das gefühl so mein leben
so richtig in der hand zu haben und ja
jetzt in der letzten zeit kommt dass so
ein bisschen weh
wieder irgendwie eine essenz ziehen
wollte sucht euch irgendeine sache
irgendwie sache die ihr euch irgendwie
interessiert sei es sport laufen muay
thai fußball oder sowas wie schach da
ist so was wie lesen sei es was wie
tischtennis irgendeine sache die auch
irgendwo interessiert und die ich ein
bisschen spaß macht ihm einfach pvp
nicht so deutlich minecraft pvp dafür
aus und dann investiert einfach mal
wirklich zeit in die sache und gebt gas
dabei und guckt wie bei dir kommt und
ich sage euch ihr werdet weit kommen es
wird euch ein sehr sehr gutes gefühl
dafür geben dass ihr selbst sehr wohl in
der lage seid ihr leben zu beeinflussen
und steuern zu können wohin das geht das
kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen also
nicht durch irgendeine sache und zieht
die durch gebt euch irgendwann jahr zwei
jahre zeit gibt gas wenn irgendwie ein
macht die sache richtig also macht's
richtig und gibt da wirklich gas dabei
also wenn ihr die stelle ist euch auch
so für sowas dann die klärung dreimal
die woche zum tischtennis training
morgen aussieht dann macht regelmäßig
ihren sport betreiben laufen pro woche
oder wenn sie irgendwas anderes ist
lesen zum beispiel sonne geile
aktivitäten sagte loki ab jetzt lese ich
jeden tag zwei stunden im buch und gab
mir ihr werdet richtig krasse
entwicklung beobachten er also schon
krass bei mir hat diese prozesse zu
merken dass man das eigentlich selbst
irgendwo in der hand hat 20 jahre wieder
ort auch wenn es jetzt eine sehr
persönliche sache ist auch meine mutter
meinte was ich bilder aus seiner kinder
zeigen das ist hier nicht so heftig
nicht mehr dazu irgendwas zu recht
dachte ich mir dann auch wenn ich dafür
20 jahre gebraucht habe
dann kann ich euch da draußen die
vielleicht 14 15 16 12 oder 20 oder 25
30 sind bei denen es vielleicht noch
nicht so eingetreten ist dieses gefühl
für was man selbst ist für das man das
leben auch irgendwo selbst in der hand
hat und das ist nicht nur an einem
vorbeizieht
ja das wollte ich einfach ausbauen ich
bin sehr gespannt wie das video bei euch
ankommt
ich weiß nicht ob viele von euch
irgendwie das fühlt was hier gerade
gemacht arbeite ich hoffe dass irgendwo
angekommen bei euch weiß das so ist
könnt ihr gerne auch gedanken zu dem
thema in die kommentare schreiben
und wirklich glaubt mir leute suchte ich
irgendwie sache und zieht die durch
wirklich gas damit es würden auf jeden
fall positiv beeinflussen egal was ist
außerdem zu störungen also damit solche
richtig tief aber ich glaube dass sich
von selbst ja das waren meine gedanken
zu dem thema sehr chaotisch wie gesagt
ich hoffe irgendwann es mit gekommen
falls ja alle sondern die kommentare
feedback in den kommentaren gedanken in
den kommentaren alles die kommentare und
das journal of it und bis zum nächsten
mal